dans les annales judiciaires impossible
de trouver un cas de figure identique du
jamais vu un procès en révision qui
reconfirme la culpabilité de l'accusé et
contre l'avis de l'avocat général
sa demande d'explication dominique
wernert côté c'est vrai bien triste que
ce procès est annoncé comme devant être
celui de l'innocence reconnu de patrick
10 et donc par ricochet celui de la
culpabilité de francis heaulme
ce fut en tout cas la tonalité jusqu'au
réquisitoire d'hier matin une sorte de
chronique annoncée d'un acquittement et
puis 16 heures plus tard ce fut le grand
écart fine il intime conviction de
l'avocat général finit la présence de
francis heaulme
les douze jurés de la cour d'assises dès
mineurs ont écarté balayé le doute est
l'élément nouveau qui avaient été
avancés par les magistrats de la cour de
révision et le huis clos imposé par la
loi ne nous empêche aujourd'hui de
comprendre d'expliquer ce verdict alors
qu'historiquement révision était c'est
vrai un peu synonyme d'innocence
d'acquittement l'adage n'est plus vrai
un procès en révision est désormais un
procès en appel
sorte de rattrapage extraordinaire donc
retournement de situation puisque le
présumé innocent dils et condamné pour
le double meurtre et aux yeux de la
justice et bien francis heaulme reste un
suspect est ce que patrick dils a
intérêt maintenant à faire appel écoutez
c'est toute l'ambiguïté de ce verdict
parce qu'ayant déjà purgé 14 en
détention patrick dils peut espérer une
libération conditionnelle dans les mois
qui viennent pour cela il ne doit pas
faire appel de sa condamnation
s'il fait appel il sera rejugé disons
dans un an mais sa remise en liberté est
plus qu'hypothétique et puis ne pas
faire appel c'est aussi dit-on
reconnaître sa culpabilité alors c'est
un choix cornélien entre l'honneur et la
liberté
merci dominique d'intérieur